tell her i'll tell her things that she
doesn't want to hear i don't care
give me an example yeah so so she'll be
like you know are you seeing other
people yes
plenty of them they're pretty you might
like this blonde i've been seeing i mean
just tell them man and then and if she's
like oh my god you're gross well how do
you respond they don't they don't they
don't because they already
subconsciously know you see other women
so they respect them but that's fine on
a first date not the 12th date i'll tell
you i was dating this girl for a long
time we're driving down the road
and she was telling me about how she
left her fiance because he cheated on
her i said no you didn't
and she told me a week later she said i
was mad at you but when you said you
didn't you didn't break up with him
because he cheated you broke up with him
because he was too much of a coward to
admit it hmm yup
that's why she left
so that's a very important part is she
more
upset about the cheating or the lying
the lying because he's a coward because
every woman knows deep down any man that
is on any kind of level has women that
want him
period and i'm not saying what he should
do
i'm just simply saying i don't think she
left so much because of his action so
much as his cowardness of running from
her
and not and not leaning into what the
facts of the matter was because
everybody knows that if you took every
man in the world and you said listen you
can
hit this button
and
sleep with as many women as you want but
you get to go home every night and love
your wife
hold her be a good father be a good man
all you have to do is hit this button
and everything will be fine and you can
do that and the other thing every man
would look left look right and be like
hit that button
have your cake and eat it too is what
you're saying yeah but would you ladies
put up with that a man that truly loves
you would never let you find out
[Music]